well for five years we have watched the
news media treat donald trump in a way
that no american president has ever been
treated
richard nixon himself disgraced
impeached force from office in the end
got a pass by comparison to donald trump
reporters
hate trump with an all-consuming mania
they hate him
so intensely that at times it's been
amusing to watch
if donald trump announced a cure for
cancer at tonight's rally in minnesota
cnn would denounce him for fixing drug
prices that's true
if you're a fair-minded person it has
been infuriating to watch us it's too
dishonest
it's also patronizing because it's
almost unbelievably stupid
trump spied for russia trump works for
putin trump's a racist because he likes
borders and doesn't want to live in
haiti
yeah okay clearly all the smart kids
went into finance
america's websites and tv stations got
the rest unfortunately we've got to live
with the consequences of that
but we should also say if we're being
entirely honest that as grating as all
of this is
unremitting hostility to the president
of the united states is far from the
greatest threat america faces
reporters are supposed to be tough on
people with power that's why we have
journalism
to keep a close eye on those who have
outsized influence
over our lives the people we should
watch carefully would include
business moguls the intel agencies
prominent academics cultural figures
military leaders
and most obviously our politicians the
rest of us can't really know
what these people the people in charge
are doing at all times
a reporter's job is to find out and tell
us so in the end the real threat to
america isn't
too many nasty questions from reporters
it's the opposite of that the real
threat is collusion
when journalists strike secret alliances
with the very people they're supposed to
be holding accountable we are in deep
trouble lies go unchallenged
democracy cannot function and that's
what we're watching right now
yesterday and this may be the starkest
example of all we learned that the fbi
is conducting an
active investigation into joe biden's
son for business deals that apparently
included his father the former vice
president
now that is not speculation it is
confirmed
former biden business partner tony
babalinsky sat for a five-hour
interview with six fbi agents just the
other day a week ago
they asked him about his business
dealings in china with the biden family
now we don't know if this investigation
will result in indictments obviously we
know that it could
and that's significant because joe biden
as you may have heard is running for
president the election is on tuesday
so by any possible measure this is a
blockbuster stop the press's news story
it's not some naughty picture from
somebody's laptop this is a criminal
investigation into business deals that
we know for a fact
joe biden was party to so why haven't
you heard more about this
if you don't watch this channel you've
likely heard nothing at all not a word
and you know why because the media are
collaborating
they're collaborating with the
democratic party they're collaborating
with the intelligence agencies that spy
on americans with impunity
they're collaborating with the tech
monopolies that have choked off the
average person's access to legitimate
information
we're not overstating any of that we
wish we were
watch the people you're supposed to be
able to trust
dismiss a completely legitimate verified
news story as quote a russian plot
holding super super spreader events and
giving russian disinformation spreading
russian disinformation
disinformation that he knows to be
fabricated and supplied
by a foreign intelligence service and
despite the warning
he's still doing it you have said this
entire thing is so
obviously a russian plot it's sort of
a crazy quilt at this point uh which has
all the hallmarks of of russian
disinformation that said
it wasn't for lack of trying rudy
basically functioning as a russian
asset by pushing russian disinformation
cnn reported on friday that u.s
authorities are seeing if those emails
we just talked about
are connected to an ongoing russian
disinformation effort
huh i've got to tell you keith it is all
the
hallmarks of russian disinformation
these people wouldn't know russian
disinformation if it got into the shower
with them
they know nothing every word of what
they just said was a lie
russia didn't forge these emails
vladimir putin didn't invent the two
separate meetings that tony babilinski
had with joe biden to discuss business
in china
the business the fbi is now
investigating in an active criminal
investigation
that's all entirely real it happened it
is happening now and the people you just
watched on the screen
know that it did yet they're telling you
it's all
fake a concoction of a hostile foreign
power
so you have to ask yourself at some
point why would they tell you that
they know it's not true they're saying
it anyway they're expecting you to
believe it why are they doing that well
because these people are not your allies
they're not trying to help you or inform
you just the opposite
these people are your enemies they're
misleading you so that you will obey
and maybe it'll work honestly maybe they
will get joe biden elected president
next week without even asking the most
basic questions of the candidate the
most basic questions or
vetting him in any way that could work
that's the gambit but what then
many of these people you just saw on the
screen will then go to work for biden
officially
we'd expect that because without donald
trump to hyperventilate over
the business models at many news outlets
will collapse
and these people will need jobs but joe
biden and kamala harris can't
hire everyone at nbc some of these
people have to continue to be quote
journalists and the question is can they
really do that
can they keep pretending on your screen
live every night
after everything we have just witnessed